[Music]
let's go to sarah in cincinnati ohio
i don't know where that accident's from
but we're gonna go with it what's up
sarah
hi how are you john how are you so good
how are you
i say so good it's great i've got coffee
i work in the air conditioning and we're
doing okay how about you
good i'm doing fine doing fine so what's
up
i'm calling because one of our dogs
was recently diagnosed with cancer
and i'm wondering how to best handle it
with my young kids oh great question how
old are your kids
well in particular my son he's four and
a half he'll be five in february but my
daughter's two so she's not real
not my biggest concern it's more him
that i'm concerned with
wow tell me about this dog
oh he's the best
we we've had him he's 10 and a half um
he's a pity boxer mix and he's just
super sweet and
loving and
[Music]
he's honestly like the best dog we could
have ever gotten so that's so great and
was it just a ride or die through the
through the birth of your kids too
oh yeah
yeah he he was he's been a protector and
he cuddles them and loves them and
kisses them and
loves them
so
we deal with a lot of hard stuff on this
show
this may be the closest i get to tearing
up okay so i'm gonna work hard because i
love dogs i think they
i think they're pretty remarkable
um
so here's
i'll just jump right into this can i
tell you a story about myself yeah
yeah um i had a
beloved dog
and in fact
i used to tell my wife this dog was in
my bed long before you were so let's
just get priority straight right uh that
dog um she was an old basset hound she's
smelled so bad
um shared a pillow with me i mean it's
obnoxious but that dog was lit he was
incredible
and when i moved that dog moved with me
that dog was ride or die disgusting
gross all the things you would think a
21 year old
guy just you walk into their apartment
like what is this it was that uh but i
love that dog and then we got another um
basset down named baxter and that dog
was rad too
molly passed away before molly died um
before we had kids
and baxter was still around when i had
hank
and
um that's right when i was learning
about trauma and how it works and what
is the best way to navigate some of this
especially with little kids
so i'll tell you about something that
happened um got news that um
baxter
was not gonna make it
and
we sit very similar and so i called a
buddy
and we were going out to to his ranch
that day just to the kids to run around
and i was at the
veterinarian's office and i'd taken the
dog in and we're gonna put the dog down
and something felt weird and so i called
him
and said hey would it be weird if i
you know we i'm gonna be i'm with the
vet now we're gonna put the dog down and
i brought the dog out to the ranch we
buried him there and says that weird i
know there's kids running around and
he's a rancher he's very very very wise
and he said something that stuck in my
soul
he got quiet and said if you don't take
this opportunity
to teach your son
about death
you failed them
and i thought well hey that's a little
bit harsh that's just how ranchers talk
to each other right
um and so i got out to the ranch um
we put the dog down and i held the dog
through the whole thing and i think
that's really important by the way is
that you hold that dog through that
season
uh my kid was not there for that moment
okay that was a lot
um
but
when i got out to the ranch my buddy had
set out one big shovel for me and one
little shovel for my son
and
we
both
dug the grave together and there's a
physical component to grief
we
prayed for that dog
and we talked about the fun and the joy
that that dog had brought us
the tender moments the hugs the things
that we were gonna miss
and my son watched me tear up
and then i watched i had to answer some
hard questions like daddy we can put the
dirt on top
and as he was processing oh this is it
this
this is it there's a finality to it
and my buddy in the distance it's it's
my single most prized possession outside
of humans
took a photo and it's of a couple
hundred yards away of me and my son
digging that grave together and i'll
keep that as long as i live it was an
important moment for me as a dad and as
somebody who teaches about grief and who
walks through hard stuff with people
so what i would tell you is
the last great gift this dog will give
to you
is to
have a create a touchstone moment for
you
and your son especially but even your
two and a half year old
that will
will ride through the next five 10 15
years of y'all's life
because here's what happened in our home
just a few years later that my granddad
passed away
and i was able to point back to hey
remember when
and then my grandmother passed away hey
remember when
and so baxter's legacy through our
family has been significant
and it was hard
and it was absolutely right
and good
and so what i would tell you is as my
friend rachel cruz says share don't
scare so be honest you don't have to be
um
overly detailed and
i don't think a four-year-old should be
in there when they give your dog a shot
or anything like that
i do think if at all possible if y'all
can
bury your dog together i think that's
really important i think that's a neat
moment and it'll be heavy it'll be hard
and there will be tears and there'll be
hugs
and there'll be lots of hard hard
questions i probably wouldn't have my
two and a half year old out there just
because there's some
there's some gaps there developmentally
but i would tell them that the dog's
really really sick and the dog's going
to die and it's not going to be here
anymore
and then when she asks questions it's a
matter of fact stuff it's bending down
and looking your two-year-old in the eye
and saying
remember remember he died he's not here
anymore and we really miss him and then
she may say i really miss him too
and
it's good for her to see mom miss so
what's this dog's name
jack jack jack jack
tell me one awesome thing about jack
jack
oh man
he's he's like your basket he he's a
mama's boy he lays on my pillow he
he is i guarantee you jack smells better
than my than molly did
for sure
i don't know
i don't
know about that
can i ask you would you
tell him ahead of time that it's
happening or would you wait until
um
uh
i think that's up to you guys i think
that's okay i don't think there's a
right way or wrong way to do that um i
would probably
um
let them know that i have to take the
dog to the to the dog doctor to the
veterinarian's office because uh he's
very very sick
okay and then when we go there we can
let him know that he died then he died
there
and then
again asking hard questions we gave him
a shot to make him feel better because
he was hurting so much
and he goes to sleep and gently
dies and be direct with your language
not evasive not passed away that doesn't
mean anything to a four year old
um letting making sure you say the words
jack jack died
right and um
it was it was
um it was jack jack's time jack jack was
sick very very sick and this body got
tired
and um i would avoid he didn't feel good
so we gave him a shot i think a
four-year-old might internalize the next
time he gets a cough like he's gonna be
hiding under his bed or something from
mom
right um
but
let's give him the gift of
learning of the hard realities of life
and that people we love and things we
love and pets we love pass away they die
and that mom's gonna be there and walk
alongside us through this whole
situation
so sarah i know this is a show about
people
but my heart's broken for you guys i'm
glad that you had to had that experience
with jack jack hey can i tell you this
one more thing
yes it's a strange thing about dogs
and i'm intentionally not talking about
cats because i think cats are evil i
think they're the worst animal ever
created and i know there's a few cat
listeners of this show so
send me your mean tweets i don't even
know how twitter works so tweet away but
dogs man
cats maybe two but they live that eight
to twelve year
time period
and they tend to mark decades for us
right
it tends to be the during college and
then the first job or
when i met my
significant other through the dating and
then the first couple of hard years of
trying to figure out how we're gonna be
married together
or couldn't have kids and then tried and
then had kids in the first couple years
again so they mark seasons
and often when our dog passes away it's
as though it's it's a page turn in our
home just because of that decade time
does that make sense
so you're gonna miss jack jack and
you're gonna have this heavy realization
that you're in a new season of life
does that make sense honor that for
yourself
because it's real and it's heavy it's
hard
yeah
and
are you married
yes yes and you got two little ones
two little ones yeah there's a very real
reality that will set in that
this is the new world
there's no going back
it's not just you and your husband and
jack jack going on hikes or staying up
too late or jack being like hey what's
going on back there right all that's
over now you got two little kids and so
you're in that season now and there's
something about grieving man there's the
end of party time and now i'm just mom
with two kids and husband and now we get
to recreate some new adventure going
forward
but it just sent i don't know there's
something about that decade time period
it just tends to be snapshots and i've
just man been so fortunate to
have some ride or die old dogs that have
been with me in these just snapshot
seasons
and um i don't know i just think dogs
are amazing so
good for you sarah for giving jack jack
the
mama who loved him
glad he protected you from knucklehead
husband and brought you through with two
little ones what a magical magical
journey
and uh
high five to you in the new season build
something great